OK, so Dad, so you have the script.
好的，爸爸，剧本在你手上吗？
I have the script. From WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life , the Father's Day edition.
剧本在我手上。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》父亲节特辑。
Dad, you are such a pro.
爸爸，你真是太专业了。
I haven't done this in 40 years. It brings back all kinds of memories.
我已经四十年没干这个了。这勾起了我各种回忆。
Now you better explain to our radio listeners in what context you actually sat in front of a radio microphone, Dad.
现在，你最好给我们的广播听众解释一下，你当年到底是在什么情况下坐在广播话筒前的，爸爸。
Well, it was around 1955 or 1956 when I graduated from Maryland. Instead of getting an honest job, I went to work in radio.
嗯，那是1955年或1956年，我刚从马里兰大学毕业。我没有去找一份正经工作，而是跑去做了广播。
So here's a tape of what you sounded like back in 1956 on the radio.
那么，这儿有一段你1956年在广播里的录音。
Oh, please don't play that tape.
哦，拜托，别播那段录音。
This is three years before I was born, and you're just a kid in this recording. You are 23 years old.
那是在我出生前三年，那时候你还是个孩子。你才23岁。
Do personal problems and worries have you down? Are you disturbed by business problems, marriage problems, or emotional problems? See Mrs. K., reader and advisor. Mrs. K., formerly of Europe, gives you a reading and answers all your questions for just $1 and you'll feel much better.
你有个人问题和烦恼吗？你被商业问题、婚姻问题或情感问题困扰吗？去见见K太太，她是一位阅人咨询师。K太太曾旅居欧洲，只需花1美元，她就能为你提供解读并回答你所有的问题，你会感觉好多了。
Dad, how could somebody who's charging $1 for a reading even afford to buy a radio ad?
爸爸，一个算命只收1美元的人，怎么负担得起广播广告费的？
Well, look, she's been to Europe. She got her education there, so they must have taught her something over there.
你看，她去过欧洲。她在那里接受过教育，所以他们在那里肯定教了她点什么。
Now at some point, you gave up your career-- your burgeoning career in radio-- really before it took off the ground and that was because?
后来你放弃了你的职业——你那蒸蒸日上的广播事业——其实是在它刚起步的时候就放弃了，这是为什么？
It was nothing important. It was something called making a living.
没什么大不了的。为了谋生而已。
Right. And so now you're a certified public accountant living in Baltimore.
对。所以你现在是巴尔的摩的一名注册会计师。
Right.
没错。
Well, let me say this. Let me give a little explanation that we try to give each show for new listeners. Each week on our program we document stories of life in these United States using all the tools of radio storytelling, documentaries, monologues, found tapes, anything we can think of. And today for Father's Day my co-host will be my own father, Barry Glass, certified public accountant.
好吧，让我这么说吧。我先给新听众简单介绍一下我们每期节目的宗旨。每周我们的节目都会利用广播叙事的所有工具，包括纪录片、独白、发现的录音带，以及任何我们能想到的方式，来记录美国土地上的生活故事。今天，为了父亲节，我的联合主持人将是我的父亲，巴里·格拉斯，注册会计师。
And it's a real kick to do this.
能做这件事真是太带劲了。
I know. This is our little Father's Day adventure together.
我知道。这是我们父子俩小小的父亲节冒险。
You could have bought me a tie.
你本可以给我买条领带的。
Dad, why don't you read the billboard.
爸爸，你读一下节目预告吧。
Our program today will have four acts. Act One, Sandra Tsing Loh finds out that the world sees her father very differently from the way she sees him. Act Two, Dad's Music. We have a story from writer Sherman Alexie. Act Three, The Moment Dad Left. Act Four, Reconciling With Dad, a story from playwright Beau O'Reilly.
我们今天的节目共有四个部分。第一部分，桑德拉·清·洛发现世界眼中的她父亲与她眼中的截然不同。第二部分，爸爸的音乐。我们有作家谢尔曼·亚历克西带来的故事。第三部分，爸爸离开的时刻。第四部分，与父亲和解，一个来自剧作家博·奥莱利的故事。
So Dad, take us into Act One, will you please?
那么爸爸，带我们进入第一部分吧，好吗？
Act One, How the World Sees Your Father.
第一部分，世界眼中的你的父亲。
So, Dad, our first story today is from Los Angeles. It's from Sandra Tsing Loh as you said at the beginning of the show in the billboard. When she was growing up, her father was not a fun dad. He himself had been orphaned in Shanghai when he was twelve. He was raised in poverty, and because of that he was just this-- penny pincher doesn't even capture it. He was miserly. They didn't celebrate Christmas. He never took his children to Disneyland even though it was less than an hour away from their home. There were no real vacations.
那么，爸爸，我们今天第一个故事来自洛杉矶。就像你在节目开头的预告里说的那样，它来自桑德拉·清·洛。她小时候，她父亲并不是一个有趣的爸爸。他自己在十二岁时就成了上海的孤儿。他在贫困中长大，正因为如此，他简直——吝啬这两个字都还不够形容他。他极其小气。他们家不过圣诞节。他从不带孩子去迪士尼乐园，尽管离家不到一小时车程。家里没有任何真正的度假活动。
Sandra tells the story. Once she bought a book of Charlie Brown comics for $1 at a book fair, and her father threw it across the room furious at how she had wasted money. He was really strict. But as Sandra found out recently, not everyone in the world sees her father the way she does.
桑德拉讲述了这个故事。有一次她在书展上花1美元买了一本《花生漫画》，她父亲大发雷霆，把书扔过整个房间，因为觉得她浪费钱。他非常严格。但正如桑德拉最近发现的那样，并不是世界上所有人都像她那样看待她的父亲。
There's a kind of news that you're never prepared for, and here last week was mine. A friend told me that, incredibly, a local grunge band had composed a rock anthem about my dad and was performing it to great response in Malibu area clubs.
有些消息是你永远无法准备好的，上周我就遇到了这样的事。一位朋友告诉我，令人难以置信的是，当地一支垃圾摇滚乐队创作了一首关于我父亲的摇滚赞歌，并在马里布地区的俱乐部演出，反响热烈。
The group in question was called Boy Hits Car and the song, a wailing rock cri de coeur powered by Pearl Jam-like riffs, was in fact called "Mr. Loh." The actual cover of the Boy Hits Car demo tape was a grainily xeroxed photo of a tiny, wizened 76-year-old Chinese man, grinning on a Malibu beach in tattered swim trunks, which was indeed my father. I have to admit, however, that the Mr. Loh in the song was not one I was familiar with.
这支乐队名叫“男孩撞车”（Boy Hits Car），那首歌是一首充满痛苦的摇滚心声，伴随着珍珠酱乐队（Pearl Jam）式的反复乐句，名字就叫《洛先生》。这张演示录音带的封面上，是一个粗颗粒的复印照片，上面是一个76岁、又瘦又干的中国老头，在马里布的海滩上穿着破烂的泳裤咧嘴笑，那确实是我父亲。然而，我不得不承认，歌里的那位洛先生我并不熟悉。
As seen through the eyes of lifeguard slash singer Craig Rondell, Mr. Loh is a mystical dreamy figure who swims naked among the dolphins. In the duality that characterizes certain types of rock poetry-- I'm reminded of The Doors-- the natural dance Mr. Loh does on the beach brings the listener comfort while at the same time poses a profound spiritual challenge.
在救生员兼歌手克雷格·隆德尔的眼中，洛先生是一个神秘的、梦幻般的人物，在海豚中裸泳。在某种摇滚诗歌所特有的二元论中——我想起了大门乐队（The Doors）——洛先生在海滩上那自然的舞蹈，既给听众带来慰藉，又同时提出了深刻的精神挑战。
[MUSIC - "MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR] Mr. Loh's not afraid to be naked, but some men fall from grace. They're not secure with themselves. He doesn't measure people by things we consider important. Can't seem to comprehend today, so he swims away.
[音乐 - “男孩撞车”乐队的《洛先生》] 洛先生不惧赤身裸体，但有些人却跌落神坛。他们对自己缺乏安全感。他不以我们认为重要的事物来衡量人。似乎无法理解当今世界，于是他游走了。
My first instinct was that this had to be a sick Freudian joke one of my siblings was playing on me, as in, what is the most wildly unlikely, most fraught with amazing ironies, most wacky '60s Peter Sellers film thing you can imagine could happen to our family. But, no. My father was these Malibu surfers' Eggman. He was their Walrus. I decided to meet them.
我的第一直觉是，这肯定是我的某个兄弟姐妹在跟我开一个病态的弗洛伊德式玩笑，就像是那种你能想象到的、最疯狂的、最不可思议的、充满了奇妙讽刺的、最古怪的60年代彼得·塞勒斯电影情节。但并没有。我父亲是这些马里布冲浪手眼中的“蛋人”（Eggman）。他是他们的“海象”（Walrus）。我决定去见见他们。
Craig Rondell, bass player Scott Menville, and guitarist Louis Lenard were all too happy to come into a studio and explain how their song came to be.
克雷格·隆德尔、贝斯手斯科特·门维尔和吉他手路易斯·伦纳德非常乐意来到录音室，解释这首歌是如何诞生的。
It was one day at the beach and there was about five of us just sitting in the sand, just talking. Mr. Loh came casually walking up, and he was standing there for just maybe three seconds without saying anything. And we were kind of like OK.
那是在海滩的一天，我们大约五个人坐在沙滩上聊天。洛先生随意地走了过来，他在那儿站了大概三秒钟，什么也没说。我们就有点不知所措。
And then he said, you're all victims of modern technology. I started thinking, wow, that's deep, and then he just started to talk to us. He would sing. Throughout the conversation he would start singing, and so that's where the song-- the premise-- kind of came from.
然后他说，你们都是现代科技的受害者。我开始想，哇，这太有深度了，然后他就开始跟我们说话。他会唱歌。在谈话过程中，他会突然唱起来，所以这就是那首歌的前提来源。
[MUSIC -- "MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR] Mr. Loh, will you speak to me. You're the only one I understand. Mr. Loh, will you sing to me. You're the only one who makes sense.
[音乐 - “男孩撞车”乐队的《洛先生》] 洛先生，你会跟我说话吗？你是唯一我能听懂的人。洛先生，你会为我歌唱吗？你是唯一讲得通的人。
Do you remember when you first saw my father? Go ahead, Scott.
你还记得第一次见到我父亲是什么时候吗？继续说，斯科特。
I remember-- these guys probably have earlier memories-- but it was in 1978 after the big fire came. Our house burned down and we moved to Malibu West, and I remember seeing Mr. Loh stretching naked, and then taking a shower outside naked.
我记得——这些家伙可能有更早的记忆——那是1978年大火之后。我们的房子烧毁了，我们搬到了马里布西区，我记得看到洛先生在裸体拉伸，然后在外面裸体冲澡。
At the beach.
在海滩上。
At the beach. And I thought it was kind of like funny but like not in a  bad way. I thought it was interesting. That was my first memory.
在海滩上。我觉得这很有趣，但并不是那种坏意义上的趣。我觉得这很有意思。那是我第一次记忆。
OK.
好的。
I too have similar memories. I mean, I've been at that beach in Malibu West since I was in diapers. Five, six, seven, eight years old, I was down there and I'd notice him doing somersaults in the sand or doing headstands against the wall, naked as well.
我也记得类似的事情。我是说，我从还在穿尿布时就去马里布西区的那个海滩了。五岁、六岁、七岁、八岁时，我就在那里，我会注意到他在沙滩上翻跟头，或者靠着墙倒立，也是一丝不挂。
Talking to these guys, it suddenly occurred to me who my dad really is. You know how every neighborhood has its eccentric, the cat lady, the parrot man, the guy with the umbrella hat and recycling cart who yells? Well, in my southern Californian hometown, Malibu West, my dad is that person. It's an unsettling thing to realize about one of your own parents.
和这些家伙谈话时，我突然意识到我父亲到底是个什么样的人。你知道每个社区都有自己的怪人，那个养猫的老太太、养鹦鹉的人、那个戴着伞帽推着回收车大喊大叫的人？好吧，在我南加州的家乡马里布西区，我父亲就是那个人。意识到关于自己父母之一的这一点是令人不安的。
And behind Mr. Loh's back, he was known as the Naked Handstand Man. For years I didn't even know his name. I just thought he was the Naked Handstand Man.
在洛先生背后，他被称为“裸体倒立男”。多年来我甚至不知道他的名字。我只以为他是“裸体倒立男”。
You're going to have to do the song.
你得唱那首歌了。
So a song. What do you mean, the song?
什么歌？你是说哪首歌？
Scott wrote another-- I'm going to put him on the spot.
斯科特写了另一首——我要让他当众表现一下。
Wait. There's a Naked Handstand Man song?
等等。还有一首《裸体倒立男》之歌？
Yes, of course, there's a Naked Handstand Man song. Unbelievably, the Mr. Loh song they'd recorded was only the latest in a decade long aesthetic exploration of my father on the part of Boy Hits Car bassist Scott Menville.
是的，当然有《裸体倒立男》之歌。难以置信的是，他们录制的那首《洛先生》只是“男孩撞车”贝斯手斯科特·门维尔十年来对我父亲进行审美探索的最新作品。
Ok, it was like, I was walking down the beach one day. I happened to turn and look his way. There stood a man that we all know, and his name is Mr. Loh. He stood right there with his head in the sand. He's the Naked Handstand Man. Mr. Loh. Mr. Loh. Like something like that, I mean, we were like twelve.
好吧，就像是，有一天我沿着海滩走。我正好转头看向那边。那儿站着一个人，我们都认识，他叫洛先生。他就在那儿，头插在沙子里。他是裸体倒立男。洛先生。洛先生。大概就是这样，我的意思是，那时候我们才十二岁。
I invited my father to join me and the band in the studio. He doesn't really see all the fuss about his nakedness.
我邀请了我的父亲和我以及乐队一起去录音室。他并没有把这种关于他裸体的骚动当回事。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] at Stanford University, which I went there, too, in the men's swimming pool, everybody was naked, because that's the most hygienic, most clean thing to do, you see.
[听不清] 在斯坦福大学，我也去过那里，在男子游泳池里，每个人都是裸体的，因为那是最卫生、最干净的做法，你懂的。
But if some young people want to see his nakedness as a symbol of something more important, well, my father is happy to be of service.
但如果一些年轻人想把他的赤身裸体看作某种更重要事物的象征，好吧，我父亲很乐意效劳。
The way I discovered the tape was this. One day maybe a couple months ago, I hitchhiked, and a couple young men pick me up. They said, Mr. Loh, we hear that tape about you. Oh, I say, those rascals. They did tape. They didn't tell me.
我发现这段录音的过程是这样的。大概几个月前的一天，我搭便车，几个年轻人载了我。他们说，洛先生，我们听到了关于你的那段录音。哦，我说，那些淘气的家伙。他们录了音。他们没告诉我。
And it's very nice. I feel very happy, very honored , you know. Probably if they don't write any song about me, probably nobody will ever write about me. So this is my life chance.
这真的很好。我感到非常高兴，非常荣幸，你知道的。可能如果他们不写任何关于我的歌，可能永远不会有人写我。所以这是我人生中的机会。
Of course, that's not true, because I've made my career writing about you.
当然，那不是真的，因为我职业生涯一直在写你。
Yeah, but not song, you see. You see, you're on the writing so I appreciate that, too. But I like something different. That's very precious for me, you see.
是啊，但不是歌，你看。你看，你是在写文章，我也很感激。但我喜欢不同的东西。那对我来说非常宝贵，你看。
Of course, with all due respect to the members of Boy Hits Car, in my opinion, my father's the least likely candidate to become a symbol of individual freedom, of spiritual introspection, of the healing powers of nature. After all, this is a man who believed all three of his children should get Ph.D.s in engineering or else they would starve in the street. Then again, all these things may be a matter of personal interpretation.
当然，出于对“男孩撞车”成员的尊敬，在我看来，我父亲是最不可能成为个人自由、精神内省或自然治愈力量象征的候选人。毕竟，这个男人曾坚信他所有的三个孩子都应该拿到工程学博士学位，否则就会饿死在街头。话又说回来，所有这些事情可能都是个人解读的问题。
So you see my father's nakedness as kind of a rebellion of some sort?
所以，你把我的赤身裸体看作某种叛逆？
No, not actually. He's being natural.
不，实际上不是。他在回归自然。
I feel that he has the ability to go beyond the general stereotype that America holds in that regard, and it's free.
我觉得他有能力超越美国在这方面的刻板印象，而且这很自由。
Contact with nature, now, that's very important. Now in this society, you're so busy, busy, busy, busy, busy. Not much time to talk to yourself or talk to the nature.
与自然的接触，那非常重要。现在在这个社会，你们太忙太忙了。没有多少时间跟自己对话或跟大自然对话。
Nature. But did you-- I'm just trying to remember as kids, if you encouraged us to do that.
自然。但是你——我只是在想，当我们还是孩子的时候，你有没有鼓励我们这样做？
Oh, yes.
哦，有的。
OK, when?
好的，什么时候？
We did many things. We always go along the a Beach to the garbage can to collect those aluminum cans. And we'd compete with [UNINTELLIGIBLE] family. We have to go one step ahead.
我们做过很多事。我们总是沿着海滩去垃圾桶收集那些铝罐。我们会和[听不清]一家竞争。我们得领先一步。
Not to put too fine a point on it, but a competition to collect cans for spare change is not the sort of communing with nature, say, Walt Whitman and Ralph Waldo Emerson extolled, which brings me to another point. I have to say there is something sort of poignant about sitting in a room full of young people who are hanging on to my father's every word. He's like an odd little guru, they his apostles. God knows he never got that from my sister, brother, or me. At one point for reasons too complicated to explain here, my father sang the boys in the band a Chinese folk song that he had translated into French.
我不打算说得太细，但为了零钱去收罐头的竞争，并不是沃尔特·惠特曼和拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生所赞美的那种与自然的交流，这让我想到了另一点。我不得不说，坐在一个满是年轻人、沉浸在我父亲每一句话中的房间里，有一种令人感伤的感觉。他就像是一个古怪的小宗师，他们是他的使徒。天知道我姐姐、哥哥或我从来没有得到过这种感觉。有一次，因为原因太复杂在此无法解释，我父亲给乐队的小伙子们唱了一首他翻译成法语的中国民歌。
[SINGING IN FRENCH]
[法语演唱]
Were you crying?
你哭了吗？
I must say that tears were coming.
我必须说，眼泪掉下来了。
Why? Why?
为什么？为什么？
That was just beautiful. That was just an unhindered true expression of something that I just felt that was totally genuine. It just gave me the chills.
那太美了。那是某种我感受到的、绝对真诚的表达，没有任何阻碍。这让我起了一身鸡皮疙瘩。
Should I sing another one?
我应该再唱一首吗？
Why not? Sing another one. If this makes my father happy, well, then I guess I'll try to be happy for him.
为什么不呢？再唱一首吧。如果这能让我父亲高兴，好吧，我想我会试着为他感到高兴。
[MUSIC -- "MR. LOH" BY BOY HITS CAR] Mr. Loh he finds the water and seems to wash his place off as the dolphins jump and play. He speaks to us in the sand. Do you know the meaning of life or are you just a simple man? Then he swims away.
[音乐 - “男孩撞车”乐队的《洛先生》] 洛先生找到了水，似乎洗去了他的位置，海豚跳跃嬉戏。他在沙滩上对我们说话。你懂人生的意义，还是你只是个简单的人？然后他游走了。
Dad, do you have the script for the back end?
爸爸，你有后面的剧本吗？
Yeah, I have it.
是的，我有。
OK, why don't you give the back end?
好的，你为什么不读一下结尾呢？
Sandra Tsing Loh is a writer, performer, composer, and columnist for Buzz Magazine in Los Angeles. She's the author of the book, Depth Takes A Holiday: Essays From Lesser Los Angeles. She tells stories about her father in a one woman show called, Aliens in America. It opens June 26 at Second Stage in New York City.
桑德拉·清·洛是洛杉矶《Buzz》杂志的作家、表演者、作曲家和专栏作家。她是《深度假期：来自小洛杉矶的随笔》一书的作者。她在名为《美国的异乡人》的单人秀中讲述了关于她父亲的故事。该剧将于6月26日在纽约市第二舞台剧院首演。
Dad, I am so glad we're doing this. Hey, Dad, you know, one of the things that you often complain to me about stories that you hear on public radio is that they're too long. How are we doing so far?
爸爸，我很高兴我们做了这件事。嘿，爸爸，你知道，你经常向我抱怨你在公共广播里听到的故事的一个原因就是它们太长了。我们目前进展如何？
How long was that story in total?
那个故事总共多长？
The total story is about eleven minutes.
整个故事大约有十一分钟长。
That's a pretty long piece.
那是一段相当长的内容。
Too long do you think?
你觉得太长了吗？
Yeah, I think it's too long.
是的，我觉得太长了。
Did your interest flag?
你的注意力涣散了吗？
No, my interest didn't slow down. However, if I were listening to the show at home with other distractions around, it might lag off a little bit.
没有，我的兴趣并没有减退。不过，如果我在家里一边听节目一边被其他事情分心，注意力可能会稍微分散一点。
Dad, it's time to open up Act Two.
爸，该开始第二幕了。
Act Two, Father's Music.
第二幕，父亲的音乐。
Now, Dad for this act I asked you to bring in an example of the kinds of music that you, my father, used to play around the house when I was a kid, because you had music going whenever you were home on weekends.
现在，爸，这一幕我让你带来一种你以前——也就是我父亲——在我小时候常在家里播放的音乐，因为你周末在家时总是会放音乐。
Absolutely.
当然。
OK. So what did you bring in?
好的。那你带了什么？
Well, I brought three Frank Sinatra CDs.
嗯，我带了三张弗兰克·辛纳屈的CD。
Right on. Can you just choose a song and let's pop that on?
太棒了。你能选一首歌放出来吗？
Sure.
没问题。
What have you got?
你选了哪首？
Probably my favorite Frank Sinatra song, "Lady is a Tramp."
大概是我最喜欢的弗兰克·辛纳屈的歌，《Lady is a Tramp》。
Why is this your favorite?
为什么这是你最喜欢的？
I don't know. I just like the rhythm. I like Frank Sinatra's phrasing.
我不知道。我只是喜欢那种节奏。我喜欢弗兰克·辛纳屈的演唱风格。
Oh, Dad, this really swings.
噢，爸，这首歌真的很有摇摆感。
[MUSIC -- "LADY IS A TRAMP" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐——弗兰克·辛纳屈的《LADY IS A TRAMP》]
Ira, do you remember the 60th birthday party--
艾拉，你还记得60岁生日派对吗——
Your 60th birthday party, of course.
当然是你的60岁生日派对。
--where we had the Frank Sinatra impersonator?
——我们请了弗兰克·辛纳屈的模仿者在那儿。
Sure.
记得。
He sang this there. Did a pretty good job, too. What do you think? Pretty good song?
他在那儿唱了这首歌。表现得还挺不错的。你觉得呢？是不是首好歌？
It's a great song. This next story that we're going to is by a writer named Sherman Alexie, who lives out on the West Coast. And among other things, it's about his father and his father's favorite song. And Dad, his father is, I guess, a bit younger than you.
这是一首好歌。我们要讲的下一个故事来自一位名叫谢尔曼·亚历克西的作家，他住在西海岸。除了其他内容外，故事讲述的是他的父亲和他父亲最爱的一首歌。爸，他的父亲我想大概比你年轻一点。
So it's not "Lady is a Tramp" or anything like that.
所以那不是《Lady is a Tramp》之类的歌。
No, this story is called, Because My Father Always Said He Was the Only Indian Who Saw Jimi Hendrix Play "The Star Spangled Banner " at Woodstock.
不，这个故事的标题是《因为我父亲总是说他是唯一一个在伍德斯托克音乐节看到吉米·亨德里克斯演奏〈星条旗〉的印第安人》。
During the '60s my father was the perfect hippie since all the hippies were trying to be Indians anyway. But because of that, my father was always asking me, how does anybody recognize when an Indian's trying to make a social statement? But there's proof. There's evidence.
在60年代，我父亲是个完美的嬉皮士，因为当时所有的嬉皮士都在模仿印第安人。但正因如此，我父亲总是问我，当一个印第安人试图表达某种社会立场时，别人怎么认得出来？但有证据，确实有证据。
Back during the Vietnam War, my father was at one of those demonstrations against it, you know. Yeah, there's this photograph of my father demonstrating in Spokane during that Vietnam War. And the photograph made it on to the wire service and was reprinted in newspapers throughout the country. It even made it on the cover of TIME Magazine.
越战期间，我父亲参加了其中一场反战示威，你知道的。在那次越战期间，有一张我父亲在斯波坎示威的照片。那张照片通过新闻通讯社发布，并在全国各地的报纸上转载。它甚至登上了《时代》杂志的封面。
And in this photograph my father's wearing bell bottoms and this flowered shirt, and he's got red peace symbols splashed on his cheeks like war paint, and he's looking like a hippie or an Indian. Yeah, and in his hands he's holding this M-16 rifle, and the photograph captures him in that moment just before he proceeds to beat the crap out of the National Guard private lying prone at his feet. A fellow demonstrator holds a sign that is just barely visible over my father's left shoulder. It read, make love, not war.
照片里的我父亲穿着喇叭裤，穿着那件印花衬衫，脸颊上涂着红色的和平符号，就像战争涂鸦，看起来既像嬉皮士又像印第安人。照片捕捉到他那一刻，他手里拿着那把M-16步枪，正要狠狠地揍那个躺在他脚下的国民警卫队二等兵。他左肩上方有一个示威同伴举着的牌子，勉强可见，上面写着“要做爱，不要战争”。
That photographer won a Pulitzer Prize, and editors across the country had a lot of fun creating captions and headlines. I've read a lot of them collected in my father's scrapbook, but my favorite was run in the Seattle Times. The caption under the photograph read, demonstrator goes to war for peace.
那位摄影师获得了普利策奖，全国各地的编辑在撰写标题和配文时玩得很开心。我在我父亲的剪贴簿里看过很多收集起来的内容，但我最喜欢的是《西雅图时报》刊登的那篇。照片下方的配文写着：“示威者为和平而战”。
Anyways, my father was arrested, but he got lucky. At first they charged him with attempted murder, but they plea bargained that down to assault with a deadly weapon, and then they plea bargained that down to being Indian in the 20th century. He got two years and spent them in Walla Walla State Penitentiary, you know.
总之，我父亲被捕了，但他很幸运。起初他们控告他蓄意谋杀，后来辩诉交易改成了持致命武器伤人，最后又减刑为“20世纪的印第安人罪”。他被判了两年，在瓦拉瓦拉州立监狱度过。
My father made it through those two years in prison, you know, and never got into any serious trouble, somehow avoided rape, and got out of prison just in time to hitchhike to Woodstock to watch Jimi Hendrix play "The Star Spangled Banner." After all the [bleep] I'd been through, my father said, I figured Jimi must've known I was there in the crowd to play something like that.
我父亲熬过了那两年的刑期，没惹什么大麻烦，也没遭到什么侵犯，出狱后正好赶上搭车去伍德斯托克看吉米·亨德里克斯演奏《星条旗》。我父亲说，在经历了这一切之后，我觉得吉米一定知道我在人群中，所以才弹了那样的曲子。
20 years later, my father played his Jimi Hendrix tape until it wore down. Over and over the house filled with the rocket's red glare and the bombs bursting in air. He'd sit by the stereo with a cooler of beer beside him, and cry, laugh, call me over, and hold me tight in his arms, his bad breath and body odor covering me like a blanket.
20年后，我父亲反复播放那盘吉米·亨德里克斯的磁带，直到磁带磨损。一遍又一遍，屋子里充满了“火箭的红色闪光”和“空中炸开的炸弹”。他坐在音响旁，旁边放着一箱啤酒，又哭又笑，叫我过去，把我紧紧拥在怀里，他那糟糕的口臭和体味像毯子一样笼罩着我。
Jimi Hendrix and my father became drinking buddies. Jimi Hendrix waited for my father to come home after a long night of drinking, and here's how the ceremony'd work. I would lie awake all night and listen for the sounds of my father's pickup. And when I heard it, I'd run downstairs, turn on the record player, and Jimi Hendrix would break into "The Star Spangled Banner" just as my father walked in the door. He'd salute, walk over to the table, sit down, and start drinking some more, or I'd walk over there, lay down at his feet, and he'd pass out on the table. I'd fall asleep at his feet and we'd dream the same dreams.
吉米·亨德里克斯和我父亲成了酒友。吉米·亨德里克斯等着我父亲在漫长的酒后回家，仪式是这样的：我会整夜不睡，听我父亲皮卡车的声音。当我听到它时，我会跑下楼，打开唱片机，吉米·亨德里克斯就会在我父亲进门的那一刻响起《星条旗》的乐章。他会敬个礼，走向桌子，坐下来继续喝，或者我会走过去躺在他的脚边，然后他就在桌子上睡着了。我会在他脚边睡着，我们做着同样的梦。
And then when he woke up in the morning he'd feel so guilty he'd tell me stories. He talked about how he met my mother, you know. He'd say, yeah, me and your uncle Raymond were sitting in the Pow Wow Tavern when your mother came walking in. And she was real tall, about six feet tall, you know, just beautiful. And your Uncle Raymond turned to me and said, she's real tall, ain't it? And I said, yeah. And your Uncle Raymond said, what tribe do you think she is? And I said, Amazon. And your Uncle Raymond leaned in real close to me and said, their reservation's in Montana, isn't it?
第二天早上他醒来时，会感到很内疚，于是就会跟我讲故事。他会谈到他和我母亲是怎么认识的。他说，我和你雷蒙德叔叔坐在波瓦瓦酒馆里时，你母亲走进来。她长得很高，大约有六英尺，简直美极了。你雷蒙德叔叔转向我说，她真高，不是吗？我说，是啊。你雷蒙德叔叔说，你觉得她是哪个部落的？我说，亚马逊部落的。你雷蒙德叔叔凑过来低声说，她们的保留地在蒙大拿州，对吧？
Your mother and I ended out that night sitting on the hood of a '65 Malibu, both smoking cigarettes and coughing away. Neither of us smoked but we both thought the other one did.
那天晚上我和你母亲最后坐在了一辆65款马里布汽车的引擎盖上，两人抽着烟，不停地咳嗽。我们都不抽烟，但都以为对方抽烟。
Somehow my father's memories of my mother grew more beautiful as their relationship became more hostile. By the time the divorce was final, my mother was quite possibly the most beautiful woman who ever lived. Your father was always half crazy, my mother told me more than once, and the other half was on medication.
不知怎么的，当他们的关系变得愈发敌对时，我父亲对我母亲的回忆却变得越来越美好。等到离婚最终判决时，我母亲很可能是史上最美的女人。我母亲不止一次告诉我，你父亲一直半疯不癫的，另一半还靠吃药维持。
Yeah, one night my father and I were driving home in a blizzard after a basketball game, you know, listening to the radio. We didn't talk much. And we heard this DJ on the radio. Hello, out there, folks. This is Big Bill Baggins with the late night classic show on KROC 97.2 on your FM dial. We have a request here from Betty in Teco. She wants to hear Jimi Hendrix's version of "The Star Spangled Banner" recorded live at Woodstock.
有天晚上，在一场暴风雪中，我和父亲在看球赛后开车回家，听着收音机。我们没怎么说话。我们听到收音机里那个DJ说：“嘿，外面的朋友们。我是大比尔·巴金斯，正在主持KROC 97.2调频的深夜经典节目。我们收到特科（Teco）的贝蒂的一个点歌。她想听吉米·亨德里克斯在伍德斯托克现场录制的《星条旗》版本。”
My father smiled, turned the volume up, and we rode down the highway while Jimi led the way like a snowplow. Until that night, I'd always been neutral about Jimi Hendrix. But in that near blizzard with my father at the wheel, with the nervous silence caused by the dangerous roads and Jimi's guitar, there seemed to be more to all that music. That reverberation came to mean something to me, you know, something specific, something Indian.
我父亲笑了，调大了音量，我们行驶在公路上，吉米像扫雪机一样领着路。在那晚之前，我对吉米·亨德里克斯一直不置可否。但在那场近乎暴风雪的天气里，我父亲开着车，危险的道路和吉米的吉他声带来的紧张寂静中，那音乐似乎有了更深层的意义。那种共鸣对我来说意味着什么，某种具体的、某种印第安的东西。
You know, I said to my father, my generation of Indian boys ain't never had no real war to fight. The first Indians had Custer to fight. My great-grandfather had World War One. My grandfather had World War Two. You had Vietnam. All I had was video games. My father laughed for a long time, nearly drove off the road into the snowy fields.
你知道，我对我父亲说，我们这一代印第安男孩从来没有真正打过仗。最早的印第安人有卡斯特要对付。我曾祖父经历了第一次世界大战。我祖父经历了第二次世界大战。你经历了越南战争。我只有电子游戏。我父亲笑了很久，差点把车开进路边的雪地里。
We kept driving through the snow and talked about war and peace. Those are the kind of conversations that Jimi Hendrix forced us to have. I guess every song has a special meaning for someone somewhere. I mean, Elvis Presley is still showing up in 7-11 stores across the country even though he's been dead for years. So I figure music just might be the most important thing there is. Music turned my father into a reservation philosopher. Music, a powerful medicine.
我们继续在雪中行驶，谈论着战争与和平。那是吉米·亨德里克斯强迫我们进行的对话。我想每首歌对某处的人都有特殊的意义。我的意思是，猫王即使死了多年，依然出现在全国各地的7-11便利店里。所以我认为音乐可能是最重要的东西。音乐把我父亲变成了一位保留地哲学家。音乐，是一种强大的良药。
You know, my father told me once, I remember the first time your mother and I danced. We were in this cowboy bar. We were the only real cowboys despite the fact that we're Indians. We danced to a Hank Williams song. You know, Hank Williams was a Spokane Indian. Danced to that real sad one, you know, that I'm so lonesome I could cry, except your mother and I weren't lonesome or crying. We just shuffled along and fell right god damn down in love.
你知道，我父亲有次告诉我，我记得你母亲和我第一次跳舞的时候。我们在一家牛仔酒吧里。尽管我们是印第安人，但我们是现场仅有的真正牛仔。我们随着一首汉克·威廉姆斯的歌跳舞。你知道，汉克·威廉姆斯是斯波坎印第安人。跳的是那首真正的悲伤的歌，你知道，《I'm so lonesome I could cry》，只不过你母亲和我并不寂寞也不想哭。我们只是挪着步子，该死地坠入了爱河。
Hank Williams and Jimi Hendrix don't have much in common, I said. Hell, yes, they do. They knew all about broken hearts, my father said. You sound like a bad movie, I said. Yeah, well, that's how it is. You kids today don't know [BLEEP] about romance, don't know [BLEEP] about music either, especially you Indian kids. You've all been spoiled by those drums. You've been hearing them so long you think that's all you need. Hell, son, even an Indian needs a piano, a guitar, a saxophone now and then. My father played in a band in high school. He was the drummer. I guess he had burned out on those. Now he was like the universal defender of the guitar.
我说，汉克·威廉姆斯和吉米·亨德里克斯没什么共同点。我父亲说，去你的，他们有。他们都深知心碎的滋味。我说，你听起来像部烂电影。他回答，是啊，生活就是这样。你们这些孩子现在对浪漫一窍不通，对音乐也一窍不通，尤其是你们这些印第安孩子。你们都被那些鼓声宠坏了。你们听得太久了，以至于以为那是你们所需要的全部。去你的，孩子，即使是印第安人有时也需要钢琴、吉他和萨克斯管。我父亲在高中时组过乐队。他以前是鼓手。我想他大概是对鼓感到厌倦了。现在他就像吉他的全民捍卫者。
A few years back my father packed up the family and the three of us drove to Seattle to visit Jimi Hendrix's grave. We had our photograph taken lying down next to that grave. There isn't a gravestone there, just one of those flat markers. That's all that's left of Jimi Hendrix. He was 28 when he died. That's younger than Jesus Christ when he died, younger than my father as he stood over the grave. Only the good die young, my father said. Nah, my mother said, only the crazy people choke to death on their own vomit. Why you talking about my hero that way, my father asked. [BLEEP], my mother said, old Jesse Wild choked to death on his own vomit, and he ain't anybody's hero. I stood back and watched my parents argue. I was used to those battles.
几年前，我父亲收拾好家当，我们三人开车去西雅图瞻仰吉米·亨德里克斯的墓地。我们躺在坟墓旁拍了张照片。那里没有墓碑，只有一块扁平的标记。这就是吉米·亨德里克斯留下的全部。他去世时才28岁。比耶稣基督去世时还年轻，比站在墓前的我父亲还要年轻。我父亲说，只有好人才英年早逝。我母亲说，才不是，只有疯子才会被自己的呕吐物噎死。我父亲问，你为什么要那样说我的英雄？我母亲说，去你的，老杰西·怀尔德就是被自己的呕吐物噎死的，他可不是谁的英雄。我站在一旁看着父母争吵。我早已习惯了那些争斗。
After a while, after too much fighting, and too many angry words had been exchanged, my father went out and bought a motorcycle, a big Harley Davidson. He left the house often to ride that thing for hours, sometimes for days. He even strapped an old cassette player to the gas tank so he could listen to music.
过了一阵子，在经历太多的争吵和太多的恶语相向后，我父亲出去买了一辆摩托车，一辆巨大的哈雷戴维森。他经常离家，一骑就是几个小时，有时是几天。他甚至用带子把一台旧卡带播放机绑在油箱上，这样他就能听音乐了。
With that bike, my father learned something new about running away. He stopped talking so much, stopped drinking so much. He didn't do much of anything except ride that bike and listen to Jimi. Then one night my father wrecked his bike on Devil's Gap Road and ended up in the hospital for two months, you know. Ended up in this big surgery thing. Broke his legs, cracked his ribs, and punctured a lung. He lacerated his kidney, really hit his head. And the doctor said he could have died easily. They were kind of surprised he made it through surgery.
有了那辆车，我父亲学到了关于逃避的新东西。他话变得少了，酒喝得也少了。他除了骑那辆车听吉米，几乎什么都不做。然后一天晚上，我父亲在魔鬼峡谷路上出了车祸，住了两个月的院。经历了大型手术。断了双腿，肋骨骨裂，肺部穿孔。肾脏撕裂，头部也受了重伤。医生说他差点就死了。他们甚至惊讶他能挺过手术。
And my father laid there in that coma for two months, and my mother went there every day, you know. And one day my mother was there holding my father's hand, you know. And even though the doctor said if my father woke up, he might be somebody different, he might be somebody new, he might be a vegetable, my mother said on that day when she was holding my father's hand with those heart machines sounding like a drum and my father's fingers started beating along, you know, with those heart machines sounding like a drum, my mother said I knew it was your father. I knew it was him, because he was way off rhythm.
我父亲在昏迷中躺了两个月，我母亲每天都去。有一天，我母亲在那握着我父亲的手。尽管医生说如果我父亲醒来，他可能会变得面目全非，可能会成为植物人，但就在我母亲握着他手的那天，心电监护仪的声音听起来像鼓点，我父亲的手指开始随着节奏敲击，你知道，随着心跳监测器的鼓声，我母亲说，我知道那是你父亲。我知道是他，因为他完全不在节奏上。
Yeah. Yeah, and when my father finally had the strength to sit up and talk, hold conversations and tell stories, he called for me. Victor, he said, stick with four wheels. He had to learn how to walk again, and when he did, he walked out of that hospital, forgot his advice to me, and got himself a new motorcycle, you know, and he ended up leaving us completely, you know. And then I'd get postcards from Browning, Montana, and Poplar, Montana, and South Dakota. For a while I got postcards nearly every week from him. Then it was once a month. Then it was on Christmas and my birthday. And then we didn't hear from him at all.
是啊。是的，当父亲终于有力气坐起来说话、交谈和讲故事时，他叫了我过去。维克多，他说，还是老老实实开四个轮子的车吧。他必须重新学习走路，当他学会后，他走出了医院，忘了给我建议，又给自己买了一辆新摩托车，最终彻底离开了我们。之后我会从蒙大拿州的布朗宁、波普拉以及南达科他州收到他的明信片。有一阵子，几乎每周都会收到。后来变成一个月一次。再后来是在圣诞节和生日时。最后我们就完全失去他的音讯了。
My mother did her best to explain it all to me. Was it because of Jimi Hendrix, I asked her. Part of it, yeah, she said. This might be the only marriage broken up by a dead guitar player. There's a first time for everything, isn't it? I guess, she said. Your father just likes being alone more than he likes being with other people. Even me and you.
我母亲尽力向我解释这一切。我问她，是因为吉米·亨德里克斯吗？她说，有一部分原因吧。这可能是唯一一段被已故吉他手拆散的婚姻。凡事总有第一次，不是吗？我想是吧，她说。你父亲就是比和人待在一起更喜欢独处。即使是和我还有你在一起。
And then on the night I missed my father most when I lay in bed and cried with that photograph of him beating that National Guard private in my hands, I imagined his motorcycle pulling up outside. I knew I was dreaming and all, but I let it be real for a moment. Victor, my father yelled, let's go for a ride. I'll be right down, I said. I need to get my coat. I rushed around the house, pulled my shoes and socks on, struggled into my coat, and ran outside to find an empty driveway.
在我想念父亲的那个夜晚，我躺在床上，手里拿着他打国民警卫队士兵的照片哭泣，我想象着他的摩托车停在外面。我知道这只是幻想，但我让它在那一刻变得真实。维克多，我父亲喊道，去兜兜风吧。我说，我马上下来，我得去拿件外套。我在屋里跑来跑去，穿上鞋袜，挣扎着套上外套，跑出去却发现车道上空无一人。
It was so quiet. A reservation kind of quiet where you can hear somebody drinking whiskey on the rocks three miles away. I stood on the porch all night long and imagined I heard motorcycles and guitars until the sun rose so bright that I knew it was time to go back inside to my mother. She came outside, took me back inside, made us both breakfast, and we ate until we were full.
真是太安静了。那种保留地特有的安静，你可以听到三英里外有人在喝加冰威士忌的声音。我在门廊上站了一整晚，想象着听到了摩托车和吉他声，直到太阳升起，光芒万丈，我才意识到该回到母亲身边了。她出来把我带回屋内，为我们做了早餐，我们吃到饱为止。
Sherman Alexie lives in Seattle. This story comes from his book of stories, The Lone Ranger and Tonto Fist Fight in Heaven.
谢尔曼·亚历克西住在西雅图。这个故事选自他的小说集《独行侠与托托在天堂打架》。
Hey, Dad, it's time for us to give stations a chance to do the local ID breaks and local promos, so I think you have a piece of copy there in front of you.
嘿，爸，是时候让电台播放当地的ID插播和宣传了，我想你面前有一份稿子。
I do. Coming up, one father leaves, another one returns, in a minute when our program continues.
我有。接下来，一位父亲离去，另一位回归，稍后我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our special Father's Day edition. And co-hosting with me for this day is my own father, Barry Glass, now a certified public accountant in Baltimore, but once upon a time, back in his early 20s, a DJ.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们的父亲节特别版。今天和我一起担任联合主持的是我父亲，巴里·格拉斯，他现在是巴尔的摩的一名注册会计师，但在很久以前，他20出头时，是一名DJ。
Ira, you also said you wanted a song dealing with fathers.
艾拉，你也说过想要一首关于父亲的歌。
That's right. Did you bring in a song dealing with fathers?
没错。你带来一首关于父亲的歌了吗？
I did.
我带了。
What have we got?
我们有什么？
It's by somebody that you may have never heard of, because you're too young. Maybe you have. Eddie Fisher.
那是你可能从未听说过的人唱的，因为你太年轻了。也许你听说过。埃迪·费舍尔。
The only way that I know who Eddie Fisher is-- wasn't he one of Elizabeth Taylor's husbands?
我了解埃迪·费舍尔的唯一途径是——他不是伊丽莎白·泰勒的丈夫之一吗？
That's right. That's right.
没错。没错。
He was the one before the guy who she did Cleopatra with.
他是泰勒拍《埃及艳后》之前的那个人。
Right.
对。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
That's right.
没错。
How very sad for Eddie Fisher that this is all that I would know. Here I am a person in my mid-30s, an educated person, that is all I would know about him.
埃迪·费舍尔真可怜，我对他仅有的了解竟是这些。我作为一个30多岁、受过教育的人，对他竟然只知道这些。
Richard Burton was married to Elizabeth Taylor after Eddie Fisher. The name of the song is "Oh My Papa."
理查德·伯顿是埃迪·费舍尔之后嫁给伊丽莎白·泰勒的。这首歌的名字叫《哦，我的爸爸》。
[MUSIC - "OH MY PAPA" BY EDDIE FISHER]
[音乐——埃迪·费舍尔的《OH MY PAPA》]
Dad, it's like Jewish mariachi music.
爸，这听起来像犹太马里亚契音乐。
Is that on point for Father's Day?
这符合父亲节的主题吗？
You couldn't get more on point. Actually one of our producers--
再符合不过了。事实上，我们的一位制片人——
You go around singing that about your father?
你到处唱这首歌来谈论你的父亲？
I will now, Dad. I promise. At least for the day, at least for Father's Day. Do you want me to do it now?
我现在会唱了，爸。我保证。至少今天，至少为了父亲节。你想让我现在唱吗？
No, that's OK.
不，不用了。
No, I'm going to do it. I'm going to do it. No, no, I'm going to do it.
不，我要唱。我要唱。不，不，我一定要唱。
I've heard you sing, Ira.
我听过你唱歌，艾拉。
You can't stop me. When he would take me on his knee and with a smile he'd change my tears to laughter. Oh my Papa. Dad, this is going out to you. To me he was so wonderful.
你阻止不了我。当他把我抱在膝上，用微笑将我的泪水化为欢笑。哦，我的爸爸。爸，这是献给你的。对我来说他是如此美妙。
Ira, my heart is breaking.
艾拉，我的心都要碎了。
We're now at Act Three, The Moment Dad Left.
现在进入第三幕：父亲离开的那一刻。
In this act, we have a story from Jay Allison. Jay Allison is this radio producer that all the people who kind of work behind the scenes in public radio, we all know him. He just won the biggest award in public radio, the Edward R. Murrow Award. He does these really unusual little stories.
在这一幕中，我们分享一个来自杰伊·艾利森的故事。杰伊·艾利森是一位广播制作人，所有在公共广播幕后工作的人都认识他。他刚刚获得了公共广播界的最高奖项——爱德华·R·默罗奖。他经常制作一些非常独特的小故事。
He lives in Woods Hole, Massachusetts, Cape Cod, and one of his neighbors is a guy named Dan Robb. And Dan Robb is a writer and a teacher and a carpenter. And Jay and Dan had an idea for a little radio experiment.
他住在马萨诸塞州伍兹霍尔的科德角，他的邻居之一叫丹·罗布。丹·罗布是一位作家、教师，也是一名木匠。杰伊和丹曾构思过一个小小的广播实验。
Dan's father left his family when Dan was a little kid, just, I think, three or four years old. And Dan remembered that night vividly, or he thought he did, but he never discussed this with his parents. So, Dad, Jay encouraged Dan to talk to his parents about this on tape, and I'm going to play you the story they put together, OK?
丹的父亲在他小时候——大概三四岁时——就离开了家庭。丹对那个晚上记忆犹新，或者他自以为如此，但他从未与父母讨论过这件事。所以，杰伊鼓励丹在录音时和父母谈谈这件事，我要给你们播放他们一起制作的故事，好吗？
Yeah, I'd like to hear it.
好的，我很想听听。
I remember clearly the morning they told me they were separating. I was three and they leaned over my bed, which was narrow, and told me this. Something like, don't think this changes anything, but dad's moving out. And what I remember is telling them that it was not OK.
我清楚地记得他们告诉我他们要分居的那天早上。我当时三岁，他们俯身在我的小床上，对我说了这件事。大概是说，别以为这改变了什么，但爸爸要搬出去了。我记得我告诉他们这绝对不行。
Then later that day, I remember watching my father's back as he walked down the stairs outside the house. They were cement and had a black wrought iron banister running up both sides, and he was walking down the steps away from me. He had a brown tweed jacket on and brown leather shoes, and he was carrying two brown suitcases. He put them in his Jeep back when they still said Willys on the side, and he drove away.
那天晚些时候，我记得看着父亲的背影，他正走下房子外面的台阶。台阶是水泥做的，两边都有黑色的锻铁栏杆，他正走下台阶，远离我而去。他穿着一件棕色的粗花呢夹克和棕色的皮鞋，拎着两个棕色的手提箱。他把行李放进他的吉普车里——那时车身上还写着“Willys”——然后开车离开了。
The steps were cement steps pretty steep and about three flights, three little flights, three steps and then a landing and three steps down. And there was something crooked about them. One of the steps sort of went off at an angle. There was an iron railing along the way up, very pretty.
那些水泥台阶很陡，大约有三段，每段三级台阶，中间有个平台。台阶有些歪斜，其中一级似乎还斜向一边。路边有非常漂亮的铁栏杆。
Now, if I looked out the window and watched Dad packing his car and then driving away, at that time what kind of a car would it have been?
如果我当时透过窗户看着爸爸收拾车子然后开车离开，那会是什么样的车？
Well, he had bought a little sports car, because his car was in the garage-- in the shop-- and he didn't want to wait until it was ready, which would have been two or three days later. He bought a little car so that he could leave right away. And he told me he was leaving on a trip across the country, because that's what he had to do in order to clear his mind and get his feet on the ground again. So he packed up and he got in this little sports car and took off.
哦，他当时买了一辆小跑车，因为他的车在车库里——在修理店——他不想等到车修好，那还得两三天。他买了一辆小车以便能立刻离开。他告诉我他要开始一次横穿全国的旅行，因为那是他理清思路、重新站稳脚跟必须做的事。所以他收拾好行李，坐进那辆小跑车，出发了。
What kind of car was it?
那是什么车？
It was a little Triumph, a little two-door. It was a neat little car, which I sort of got special for the trip. I just drove out West. I mean, I just wanted to get away from Pittsburgh and just sort of clear my head out, I thought. I remember telling Allison that when I got back I thought I would want to move out.
那是一辆小凯旋，一辆两门的小车。那是一辆很棒的小车，为了这次旅行我特地去搞到的。我就这样开车去了西部。我的意思是，我只是想远离匹兹堡，清理一下头脑。我记得我告诉艾莉森，等我回来时我想搬出去住。
I had a lot of different feelings. I was angry that he'd done it. I was angry that he hadn't ever taken Dan and me-- you and me-- on a trip.
我有过很多种复杂的情绪。我对他这么做感到愤怒。我愤怒的是他从未带丹和我——你和我——去旅行过。
And he was walking down the steps away from me. And he was carrying two brown suitcases. He put them in his Jeep back when they still said Willys on the side, and he drove away. A little while before he left that day, he knelt down in front of me and tightened my belt for me. I have a picture of that. His hands are big, bigger than mine will ever be. Farmer's hands or a ballplayer's hands. And he is cinching the belt gently tighter and saying something to me.
他走下台阶，远离我而去。他拎着两个棕色的手提箱。他把行李放进他的吉普车里，那时车身上还写着“Willys”，然后开车离开了。在他离开那天，他曾在我面前蹲下来，帮我系紧腰带。我有一张照片记录了这个瞬间。他的手很大，比我将来任何时候的手都要大。那是农夫的手，或者球手的手。他轻轻地拉紧腰带，对我说了些什么。
I mean, I feel bad about all of the sort of gaps when I wasn't there. And all of that time, I mean, once it's gone, it's gone. You can never get it back. And relationships in many ways are built of memories, and the more memories you have, the deeper the relationship. And if you're missing several years of memories, you know, that's hard.
我是说，我对那些我不在身边的时光感到难过。所有那些时间，一旦失去，就再也找不回来了。人际关系在很大程度上是由记忆构成的，拥有的记忆越多，关系就越深。如果你缺失了多年的记忆，你知道，那很艰难。
Well, there's a snapshot of his doing your belt up for you when you were probably three or four. You were four when he left, weren't you?
嗯，确实有一张你三四岁时他帮你系腰带的抓拍。他离开时你四岁，对吧？
I don't remember exactly what the season was. It had to have been fall, I think, because I remember taking a lot of pictures of you in the subsequent weeks when we'd get together and go to the parks and stuff. And it was all autumn shots.
我不记得具体是什么季节了。我想应该是秋天，因为我记得在接下来的几周里，当我们聚在一起去公园玩时，我拍了很多你的照片。那些都是秋天的照片。
And he is cinching the belt gently tighter and saying something to me. I can't make out the words in the picture, which is black and white, and shows me standing there three years old in front of the big window that let the monochrome Pittsburgh light into the living room.
他轻轻地拉紧腰带，对我说了些什么。我听不清照片里的词句。那是一张黑白照片，显示三岁的我站在大窗户前，单色的匹兹堡光线照进了客厅。
The light is stark as if all of the coal burned to smelt the steel in that city had burned the color out of the air. And it reflects off his hair, which is smooth with Vitalis, and shows his strong jaw and the depth of his dark eyes.
光线很刺眼，就像为了冶炼钢铁而烧掉的所有煤炭已经把空气中的色彩都烧干了一样。光线照在他涂了发油的平滑头发上，勾勒出他坚毅的下巴和深邃的黑眼睛。
There was no abuse in that household, no harsh words that I could hear, just nothing. No father anymore, and my mother sobbing over the dishes in the sink.
家里没有任何虐待行为，我也没听到过任何尖酸刻薄的话，只是什么都没有了。没有爸爸了，母亲在水槽边洗碗时泣不成声。
What do you think you would have done after he had packed up his car and left? What would have been your reaction that I might have observed?
你觉得他收拾好车子离开后，你会怎么做？我观察到的你的反应会是什么？
Oh, you probably saw me sad and mournful, but then turning back to the house and trying to look cheerful. I also felt abandoned, and I felt that it was the end of marriage, the end of my hopes for marriage, the end of my hopes for a family for you and me. And he'd left us.
哦，你可能看到我悲伤而忧郁，但随即转身回到屋里，努力装出开心的样子。我也感到被遗弃了，我觉得那是婚姻的终结，我婚姻希望的终结，也是我为你我建立家庭的希望的终结。他抛弃了我们。
But I also felt, as he drove out of sight, well, thank goodness. What a sense of relief. I'm free of all that abuse and misunderstanding and bad feeling that had been going on for so long. I thought, well, at least I can be me now and not try to be something that somebody else was making me be.
但当他开车消失在视野中时，我也感到——好吧，谢天谢地。那是一种多么如释重负的感觉啊。我终于摆脱了长期以来所有的虐待、误解和不快。我想，好吧，至少现在我可以做回自己，不必再试图成为别人强加给我的样子。
The split up was my doing, and coming out of sort of a combination of my own immaturity, restlessness, dissatisfaction, inflated hopes and expectations. I guess I just felt that I'd never had any kind of freedom. Of course, I never really found freedom afterwards. You think, well, you're going to change your life and then, lo and behold, your life turns out to be about the same.
分手是我造成的，出于我自己某种不成熟、躁动、不满、膨胀的希望和期望。我想我只是觉得我从未获得过任何形式的自由。当然，后来我也从未真正找到过自由。你会想，好吧，你要改变生活，结果呢，你会发现生活其实没什么两样。
I was three, and they leaned over my bed, which was narrow, and told me this. Don't think this changes anything but Dad's moving out. And what I remember is telling them that it was not OK.
我当时三岁，他们俯身在我的小床上，对我说了这件事。别以为这改变了什么，但爸爸要搬出去了。我记得我告诉他们这绝对不行。
I didn't want him to tell you first, and he didn't want me to tell you first, so we did it together. And I remember I knew it was a terrible blow for you.
我不希望他先告诉你，他也不希望我先告诉你，所以我们一起说了。我记得我当时知道这对你来说是一个沉重的打击。
I don't remember telling you with her. You were in bed, I remember. At least I have this picture in my mind. And in that little room at Maple Heights. And I came in and I started to say something like, Dan, I'm going to be leaving and whatever I was going to say, and you somehow knew what was coming.
我不记得和她一起告诉你这件事了。我记得你在床上。至少我脑子里有这个画面。在枫树高地那个小房间里。我走进去，开始说些什么，比如，“丹，我要走了”，无论我要说什么，你似乎预感到了要发生什么。
It was not OK.
这绝对不行。
And you said, I don't want to hear it, and put a pillow over your head, and didn't want to listen. And it was a wrenching moment. It really was. I've thought since then that actually when I walked out of your bedroom that night, that that was really a major turning point in my life. And I don't know to this day whether it was for good or ill.
你说，我不想听，然后用枕头蒙住头，不想听。那是一个让人揪心的时刻。真的。从那以后我一直在想，其实那天晚上我走出你卧室的时候，那确实是我人生中的一个重大转折点。直到今天，我仍然不知道那到底是好是坏。
When my father left my bedroom, it was a turning point for me, too. It was the moment I moved outside the myth of the American family, left it, and became a part of something else, something with no affirming mythology to look forward to, and my restless memories of that day to look back on. I became a part of divorce, which is like the death of the family, and I turned down a path less well-marked, less well-lit, but I, unlike my father, no longer wonder if it was for good or for ill. It just is.
当父亲离开我的卧室时，那对我来说也是一个转折点。那一刻，我走出了“美国家庭”的神话，离开了它，成为其他事物的一部分，一种没有肯定性神话可供期待的事物，只有那一天躁动的记忆供我回首。我成为了离婚的一份子，那就像是一个家庭的死亡，我走上了一条标记较少、灯光较暗的道路，但与父亲不同的是，我不再纠结它是好是坏。它就是这样。
OK, well, I think that's about it. This will be on the radio right before Father's Day. So I'd like to wish you a happy Father's Day.
好的，我想差不多就是这样了。这段节目将在父亲节前夕播出。所以我想祝你父亲节快乐。
Oh, OK. Thank you.
哦，好的。谢谢。
You're welcome. And maybe we can make something good out of this.
不客气。也许我们能从中创造出一些好的结果。
Yeah.
是的。
So thank you so much.
太感谢了。
OK.
好的。
All right. I love you.
好了，我爱你。
Love you, man.
我也爱你，伙计。
OK. Talk to you soon.
好的。回见。
Yeah. Bye.
再见。
Bye.
Hey, Dad.
嘿，爸爸。
Yes, Ira.
在的，艾拉。
Do the next act open, please.
请开启下一幕吧。
Act Four, Reconciling With Dad.
第四幕：与父亲和解。
You know, this whole show is like go to reconciling with Dad. But you and I we don't need to reconcile.
你知道，整个节目就像是去和父亲和解。但你和我，我们不需要和解。
No, we don't.
不，我们不需要。
We don't. Well, Dad, this next story is about a father and son. The father was this pretty well known man here in Chicago named James D. O'Reilly. He was an actor here and a director from the 1960s through the 1980s.
我们不需要。好吧，爸爸，下一个故事是关于一对父子的。这位父亲是芝加哥一位相当有名的人，名叫詹姆斯·D·奥莱利。从20世纪60年代到80年代，他一直是一位演员和导演。
He's one of these people who everybody knew. He was the artistic director of the Body Politic Theater and the Court Theater, which are two theaters here in town. And he wasn't the most reliable dad. And his son is a guy named Beau O'Reilly, who's a playwright and a local musician and stages a lot of theater here in town. And Beau has this story about his father, including a moment in their lives when they did reconcile in a way.
他就是那种大家都认识的人。他曾是政治剧院和法院剧院的艺术总监，这是城里的两家剧院。他并不是最可靠的父亲。他的儿子叫博·奥莱利，是一位剧作家、当地音乐人，也在城里导演过很多剧目。博讲述了关于他父亲的故事，包括他们人生中以某种方式和解的时刻。
When I was a little kid, five or six, my father would do these big variety shows, these musical revues for college theater groups. And I would often appear with him, playing the bad kid in town or the midget clown screaming the lines of "This Old Man" from the top of a step ladder. And at the show's end, we would rush first to the bar where my father knew all the girls' names, and then to the train station to catch the last train home.
我小时候，五六岁时，父亲会做一些大型综艺节目，为大学剧团制作音乐歌舞剧。我经常和他一起登台，扮演镇上的淘气孩子，或者站在梯子上尖叫着唱《这位老人》的侏儒小丑。演出结束时，我们通常会先冲向酒吧，父亲在那里认识所有女孩的名字，然后赶往火车站，坐最后一班火车回家。
And I would get very tense then and hot in my stomach like I was going to burn up and pass out. So we would often miss the last train home and have to spend the long hours until morning waiting in the train station, my father falling quickly asleep, his huge head thrown back on the train waiting room seat. It seemed to hang in an impossible odd angle from the rest of his body like the dot at the bottom of a question mark that knows it has to be there but hangs on and unattached.
那时我会变得非常紧张，胃里热得像要烧着了一样，感觉快要晕倒了。所以我们经常错过最后一班火车，不得不在火车站熬过漫长的夜晚直到清晨。父亲很快就会睡着，他巨大的脑袋后仰在候车室的椅子上。它似乎以一种不可能的、奇怪的角度挂在身体上，就像问号底下的那一点，它知道必须在那儿，却又悬挂着，不相连。
And this scene-- my father drunk and snoring, a big question mark of a presence-- would be repeated numbers of times over the next 25 years. My father passed out at the family table on Christmas morning. My father nodding off behind the wheel. My father snoring through the still Latin mass. My father's head thrown back in the last row during my high school production of The Glass Menagerie.
这一幕——父亲醉酒打鼾，像一个巨大的问号般存在着——在接下来的25年里重复了无数次。父亲在圣诞节早晨昏睡在餐桌上。父亲开车时打盹。父亲在安静的拉丁弥撒中打鼾。父亲在我的高中戏剧《玻璃动物园》最后排打着呼噜。
But when he was awake, he was not totally present either. He was this silent brooding man home once a week for a family dinner. And I would sit up all night in that train station listening to the muted rumblings of the next morning's diesel engines and the fluttering of pigeons in the ceiling above, my father snoring made rusty and noisy by too much cigarettes and beer.
但当他清醒时，他也不完全在那里。他是个沉默寡言、郁郁寡欢的人，一周只回家吃一次晚餐。我会彻夜坐在火车站里，听着第二天清晨柴油引擎沉闷的轰鸣声，听着天花板上鸽子的扑翼声，父亲的鼾声因为抽烟和喝酒过多而变得嘶哑而嘈杂。
When I was 29, something changed between me and my father. I was 29 and very drunk most days, and I came home to Chicago to work for my father, I guess. I had rarely seen him in my alcoholic adulthood, his alcoholic adulthood having taken him away from the family circle years ago.
29岁那年，我和父亲之间发生了一些变化。那时我29岁，大部分时间都醉醺醺的，我回到芝加哥为父亲工作。我在酗酒的成年生活中很少见到他，他自己的酗酒生活早就在几年前把他带离了家庭圈子。
And when my father, he got me this job as a house manager and sometimes understudy at his theater on Lincoln Avenue. And he was warm and kind about it, I guess. This kindness was unusual. It was hard for me to recognize it. I didn't know whether it was kindness really or not. Maybe he just recognized something in my swaying walk and my overly bright loud way of speaking, a kindred alcoholic spirit.
当他——父亲，他在林肯大道的剧院里给我找了一份经理和候补演员的工作。他对此表现得既温暖又亲切，我想。这种亲切感很罕见。我很难识别这到底是不是真的亲切。也许他只是在我摇晃的步态和过于明亮、大声的说话方式中，认出了一个志同道合的酗酒灵魂。
We would from then on do our drinking together late nights at the pub next door to the theater, a pub where we could sit for hours, get a burger and a beer, a pub where my father ran a tab, and I was always on the tab. Now the pub tables were family long with my father always at the head and crowded with actors and confidantes all with one ear pointed at my father, hoping for a good joke from him, which usually came, or some word of praise which came rarer, but when delivered were always delivered with a flair and a passion.
从那以后，我们经常深夜在剧院隔壁的酒吧一起喝酒，我们在那里一坐就是几小时，吃个汉堡，喝杯啤酒。父亲在酒吧签账，我也总是在那儿签账。酒吧的桌子很大，父亲总是坐在首位，周围挤满了演员和密友，每个人都竖着耳朵听父亲说话，希望能听到他讲个好笑话，或者得到一两句表扬——这比较罕见，但说出来时总是充满激情和风采。
These tables would start full, full of people and huge pints of black Guinness and brown beer, but by one or two in the morning, they would be empty except for my father and I. Me talking loud and feverish now, lovers and women and broken hearts and politics and plays and broken hearts and lost lovers and lost women and broken hearts. And me doing most of the talking, my father nodding and grimacing and looking appropriately sad. But his eyes looking away always, scanning the bodies of the young women who moved about in the pub's waning hours.
这些桌子开始时总是坐满人，摆满了大杯的黑啤和棕啤，但到了凌晨一点或两点，就只剩下我和父亲了。我大声而狂热地谈论着爱人、女人、破碎的心、政治、戏剧……我讲得最多，父亲点头、做鬼脸，露出恰如其分的悲伤表情。但他的眼睛总是看向别处，扫描着深夜酒吧里走动的年轻女性的身影。
Sometimes these women stopped by the table to speak to my father, him finding sly ways to kiss and touch and pinch them, locking their eyes with his as if his eyes were gift enough to allow him his inappropriate touching. The pub would close with us still in it. The tables having adopted the chairs and now holding them piggyback, and my father would sign his tab with a flourish, and we would part company, Me often watching him walk slowly up Lincoln Avenue, a large man with a lordly old-fashioned head, always aware that he was like something out of Shakespeare or O'Neil. He might be swaying, but swaying with a charm and a dignity.
有时这些女人会停在桌旁和父亲说话，他总能找到狡黠的方式去亲吻、触摸和捏她们，用眼神锁定她们，仿佛他的眼神就是某种特许，允许他进行那种不恰当的触摸。酒吧关门了，我们还在里面。桌子已经叠起了椅子，父亲签下账单，我们分道扬镳。我经常看着他沿着林肯大道缓慢行走，一个高大的人，顶着一颗高贵、老派的头颅，他总是意识到自己像是出自莎士比亚或奥尼尔剧作里的人物。他可能在摇晃，但摇晃得很有魅力和尊严。
The further my father got up the street, the more real he felt to me. There. There. That was the father I knew, half a courtyard away under the hot lights doing Shakespeare's Lear or Brecht's Galileo, and I would stand on Lincoln Avenue crying, the crying of a 29-year-old drunken baby whose father is moving away, always moving away, and that baby knows he's better off having Dad go.
父亲走的越远，他给我的感觉越真实。就在那里。那就是我认识的父亲，在半个剧院之外，在热烈的灯光下表演莎士比亚的《李尔王》或布莱希特的《伽利略》。而我站在林肯大道上哭泣，那是一个29岁的醉酒婴儿的哭泣，他的父亲正在走远，永远在走远，而那个婴儿知道父亲离开对他更好。
I learned a lot watching my father's theater that year, wonderful productions of The Playboy of the Western World and Ronald Harwood's The Dresser , Brian Friel's Translations . My father's performances were always in the center of the plays, and I was the house manager.
那一年我在父亲的剧院学到了很多，那些精彩的《西方世界的花花公子》、《着装师》和《翻译》。父亲的表演总是剧中的核心，而我是经理。
I was skittish in a baggy suit and non-matching vintage ties, greeting the audience at the door and selling them coffee, but mostly watching the performances night after night. My understudy assignment was not something any of us ever expected to use, but one week here it comes. An actor could not appear, and I was to play my father's tortured, crippled son.
我穿着宽松的西装，打着不搭配的复古领带，表现得手忙脚乱，在门口接待观众并卖咖啡，但更多时间是每晚观看表演。候补演员的任务并不是我们中任何一个人想用的，但那一周机会来了。一名演员无法登台，我要扮演父亲那个备受折磨、残疾的儿子。
It was an Irish play about an Irish father and his Irish sons, and I was an Irish son, never mind that I had an Irish brogue like Ringo Starr's Liverpool, and I'd never appeared on a professional stage. There would be one rehearsal, my father not even on stage but seated in the audience, chain smoking, hung over, barking orders, orders that moved my body hot and frightened clumsily around the stage, me mumbling the lines and standing in all the wrong places.
这是一部关于爱尔兰父亲和儿子的爱尔兰剧，我扮演的是一个爱尔兰儿子，别管我满嘴都是林戈·斯塔尔那样的利物浦口音，而且我从未在专业舞台上露过面。只有一次排练，父亲甚至没上台，而是坐在观众席里，抽着烟，宿醉未醒，大声发号施令，那些命令让我的身体在舞台上笨拙地热得发烫，我咕哝着台词，站错了位置。
And the night of the performance I was pacing and shaking in the hall outside of the green room where my father and the rest of the cast were making up and preparing to perform. I could hear them talking, but they couldn't see me at all. They didn't know I was there, and one of the actors said, with a good actor's projection and precise actor's diction, get ready for amateur night. What did you say? My father said it quietly but with force. Get ready for amateur night. Well, he'll be fine. You worry about yourself. Prick.
演出当晚，我在更衣室外的大厅里踱步发抖，父亲和其他演员正在化妆和准备。我能听到他们说话，但他们看不见我。他们不知道我在那儿，其中一名演员用专业演员的投影和精准的吐字说道：“准备好迎接业余之夜吧。”“你说什么？”父亲轻声却有力地说道。“准备好迎接业余之夜。”“嗯，他会做得很好。你管好你自己就行了。混蛋。”
Now this is the only time I ever heard my father defend me, and I now realize the significance of that, but at the time I was very angry. And it was the anger that burned the fear out of me like a fog on a new hot summer Sunday, and I was fine when I hit the stage. I was understudy good enough. And when I played to my father, his eyes a deep well into the heart of Brian Friel's Translations , I actually enjoyed myself. There were moments of real emotion between us. And on the stage, my father was really there, like I could reach out and touch him, and he would really be there.
这是我唯一一次听到父亲维护我，我现在意识到了那件事的意义，但当时我非常愤怒。正是这种愤怒像夏天燥热周日的雾气一样烧掉了我的恐惧，当我走上舞台时，我状态很好。我作为一个候补演员足够出色。当我与父亲对戏时，他那深邃的眼睛仿佛探入了《翻译》剧作的核心，我确实享受其中。我们之间有了真实情感的碰撞。在舞台上，父亲真的在那里，仿佛我可以伸手触碰到他，而他也会真实地存在。
And when the lights came down, I stumbled off stage, tripping and falling in the dark. My father was waiting, his big, noble actor head shaggy with sweat, his arms open to receive me. We, hugging, missed the curtain call. Probable first for my father. He was not one to miss a curtain call.
灯光暗下时，我踉跄着走出舞台，在黑暗中绊倒。父亲在等着我，他高大、尊贵的演员脑袋因为汗水而凌乱，双臂张开接住我。我们拥抱着，错过了谢幕。这可能是父亲的第一次。他可不是那种会错过谢幕的人。
A few months later, my father fired me during his production of The Dresser by Ronald Harwood, my father playing Sir, a bullying, tyrannical, Shakespearean actor Sir. My father was not one to shrink from typecasting. And one of my assignments was to meet him in the lobby, holding a towel which he would use to wipe the makeup and sweat from his face before returning to the stage for the curtain call.
几个月后，父亲在罗纳德·哈伍德的《着装师》制作期间解雇了我，他在剧中扮演“爵士”，一个恃强凌弱、专制的莎士比亚式演员。父亲不是那种会回避本色演出的人。我的任务之一是在大厅迎接他，拿着一条毛巾，让他擦去脸上的妆容和汗水，然后再回到舞台进行谢幕。
I wasn't there with the towel. I had wandered off to the pub for a pint before the show ended. The truth be told, there were probably many nights when I wasn't there. I was off crying into the phone, running up the long distance phone bill for the theater, or selling dope out of the theater concession stand to my friends. I was 29 and drunk most of the time, and my father, he recognized me for what I was.
我没带着毛巾去那里。演出结束前，我溜到酒吧去喝啤酒了。说实话，有很多晚上我都没在那儿。我不是在电话旁哭泣，给剧院增加高额长途电话费，就是在剧院小卖部把毒品卖给朋友。我29岁，大部分时间都在酗酒，而父亲，他看穿了我是什么样的人。
I was becoming very much like him in my 29th year, and perhaps he was embarrassed and uncomfortable having to see himself in me every day. He was fired soon after from his theater on Lincoln Avenue, and we continued to meet in the pub night after night for many months.
我在29岁那年变得越来越像他，也许他每天在我身上看到自己时感到尴尬和不安。不久之后，他被那家林肯大道的剧院解雇了，而我们在接下来的几个月里继续在酒吧每晚相见。
Beau O'Reilly is a Chicago playwright. His show The Third Degrees of J. O. Breeze , is running in Chicago until the end of June. He is also performing in a play called The Trips by Jenny Magnus at the Steppenwolf Theater in Chicago.
博·奥莱利是一位芝加哥剧作家。他的剧作《J.O.布里兹的三级学位》在芝加哥演出到六月底。他还在芝加哥斯泰彭沃尔夫剧院出演了珍妮·马格努斯创作的剧目《旅行》。
So, Dad, you're sitting there in a studio in Baltimore. I'm here in Chicago. Do you have our credits?
那么，爸爸，你正坐在巴尔的摩的录音室里。我在这边芝加哥。你有我们的制作人员名单吗？
I do have your credits.
我有制作人员名单。
All right.
好的。
Our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and Ira Glass with Peter Clowney, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber. Our contributing editors are Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and the fabulous Margy Rochlin.
我们今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和艾拉·格拉斯制作，彼得·克洛尼、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与制作。我们的特约编辑是保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和出色的玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[感谢名单]
Music help today from Chicago's John Connors. The story about Dan Robb's father leaving comes from Jay Allison's ongoing series, Life Stories, which is funded by the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and the National Endowment for the Arts.
今天的音乐帮助来自芝加哥的约翰·康纳斯。关于丹·罗布父亲离开的故事来自杰伊·艾利森的系列节目《人生故事》，该节目由公共广播公司和国家艺术基金会资助。
If you would like a copy of this program, it is only $10. You can call WBEZ 312-832-3380.
如果你想要一份本节目的拷贝，仅需10美元。你可以致电WBEZ：312-832-3380。
That's 312-832-3380.
号码是312-832-3380。
That was so smooth. Or you can email the program. All emails get a response, and if you want to reach my dad, we'll help put you in contact with him, too. The email address, [email protected] .
说得真溜。或者你可以给我们发电子邮件。所有邮件都会得到回复，如果你想联系我爸爸，我们也会帮你联络他。电子邮件地址是：[email protected] 。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ的管理监督人是Torey Malatia。我是Ira Glass。
And I'm Barry Glass.
而我是Barry Glass。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life . Until then, don't drive like my father.
下周我们将带来更多《美国生活》的故事。在此之前，开车别像我父亲那样。
Don't drive like my son.
开车别像我儿子那样。